und jetzt das heute schon mit gundula
gause und claus kleber guten abend wir
gehen gemeinsam rein und wir gehen auch
gemeinsam wieder raus das war das
versprechen aller für alle als nach dem
11 september 2001 die ganze nato mit den
usa und einem weltweiten bündnis die
kontrolle über afghanistan erkämpfte
alle wussten dass sie sich in ein
gebirge und in ein land wacken in dem
schon alexander der große das britische
empire und die sowjetunion gescheitert
waren und nun verlängern die usa die
nato und die weltgemeinschaft diese
traurige reihe der geschlagenen die
gotteskrieger der taliban erobern
provinz um provinz die us armee rechnet
inzwischen damit dass auch die
hauptstadt kabul in absehbarer zeit
fallen wird was wird dann aus denen die
ihre ganze hoffnung in die versprechen
auch deutschlands gelegt und damit ihr
leben riskiert haben klaus brodbeck
erinnert an eine verantwortung aus der
man sich nicht so leicht zurück zieht
wie aus dem land am hindukusch einem
fernen land
dies ist kein gefängnis dies ist die
letzte zuflucht in afghanistan für
menschen die den deutschen geholfen
haben und für ihre familien ein geheimes
safe house in kabul das versteck und die
hilfe werden koordiniert haus magdeburg
die lager ist sehr gefährlich und sehr
schwer die kinder dürfen sich das leben
haus verlassen und auch die ortskräfte
dürfen sich nicht auf der straße zeigen
das haus bleibt geheim und die
ortskräfte sitzen beim seco aus und bat
nur ab dass die bundesregierung eine
entscheidung für diese menschen und
trifft schnell rückten die taliban vor
über rennen geradezu die afghanische
armee selbst der fall der hauptstadt
kabul scheint nur eine frage der zeit am
morgen kündigte der außenminister an die
ortskräfte so schnell wie möglich nach
deutschland holen zu wollen wir sind zur
zeit dabei ein bis zwei charterflüge zu
organisieren
die bis ende des monats noch einmal eine
größere anzahl von menschen aus dem land
heraus gebracht hat und wir werden dort
wo noch visa zu verteilen sind diese wie
sie jetzt in deutschland datei nach
wochenlangem ringen innerhalb der
bundesregierung erreicht die frage nach
dem umgang mit den us-kräften nun auch
den wahlkampf armin laschet heute in
torgau sachsen fordert was bereits
beschlossen ist ich höre über was da
alles bürokratisch hin und her
diskutiert wird
und ob der flug bezahlt wird und noch
nicht bezahlt wird das auswärtige amt
scheint da
einige bürokratische hemmnisse
aufzubauen diese menschen müssen sehr
schnell eine chance haben nach
deutschland zu kommen widerspruch kommt
nur stunden später aus den eigenen
reihen als vorgängerin im parteivorsitz
korrigiert den kandidaten der
limitierende faktor das muss man einfach
nochmal sehen liegt nicht in dem
verfahren das visa zu bekommen wir haben
gesagt wir sind auch bereit die leute
hierher zu bringen das visaverfahren der
tier durchgeführt der limitierende
faktor liegt zurzeit darin dass die
afghanische regierung darauf besteht
dass die die ausreisen einen
afghanischen reisepass haben
hunderttausende afghanen sind inzwischen
im land auf der flucht mehrere millionen
vertriebenen nachbarländer den den safe
hauses eingesperrten helfern der
deutschen aber sind alle fluchtwege
verschlossen die bundesregierung hat
jahre zeit gehabt sich auf diese
situation vorzubereiten wir wissen seit
jahren dass es passiert wird und jetzt
gilt es dass man schnell und
unbürokratisch diesen leuten und ihren
familien hilft es ist nicht nur eine
moralische verpflichtung sondern es geht
auch um den ruf deutschlands in der welt
und den karossen von den taliban
eingenommen wird dann haben die
ortskräfte auf das leben verloren ja
jetzt ist für sie keine frage wenige
wochen wenn ich trage auch
das amerikanische
verteidigungsministerium hat gerade
verkündet dass 3000 us soldaten nach
afghanistan zurückkommen werden
schnellstens in den nächsten 48 stunden
aber ihre mission dient nicht den
afghanen sie sollen
botschaftspersonal rausholen offenbar
das sehr schnell ernst zum thema
pandemie die regierungschefs von bund
und ländern haben am dienstag etwas
angekündigt was sie bisher schuldig
blieben ein neues messsystem für die
gefährlichkeit der lage jenseits der 7
tage incidents noch sagt niemand wie das
aussehen soll manche länder gehen schon
jetzt ihre eigenen wege baden
württemberg niedersachsen und auch
hamburg denkt über neue wege nach von
dort berichtet
[Musik]
der klang des hamburger hafens verheißt
freiheit und normalität es geht wieder
rund seit zwei monaten darf die nina der
pandemie das heck zu wenden und auf
große hafenrundfahrt gehen am horizont
aber wirft die stark steigende inzidenz
ihre wellen schon wieder buch voraus
schiffsführer prahl erwartet schweres
fahrwasser so losgeht dass wir abstand
halten müssen da wird das hier war ein
meter fünfzig abstand mache hier keine
lorbeeren schiff
an land flanieren die touristen eng an
eng über die symbole der pandemie doch
ist die große freiheit von dauer seit
drei wochen steigt die inzidenz in
hamburg deutlich stärker als im
bundesdurchschnitt 1 zeitpunkt verrät
den grund dafür am schulferien ende
springt die kurve fast schon steil nach
oben wir gucken nicht nur darauf wie
viel zahlen haben wir sondern gucken im
moment sehr genau auf die
altersverteilung der infizierten unter
stellen wir fest spielt sich alles sehr
wesentlich bei den menschen zwischen 16
und mitte 40 ab so dass wir im moment
noch nicht beunruhigt sind man muss aber
durchaus sagen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass alles so positiv
weitergeht die reiserückkehrer haben
also einen spürbaren effekt auf die
infektions entwicklung mindestens mal in
ballungsräumen das zeigen auch hamburgs
nachbar bundesländer in denen die ferien
ebenfalls zu ende sind vielen anderen
bundesländern steht diese entwicklung
noch bevor
es ist zu erwarten dass wir überall dort
wo die ferien zu ende gehen wenn dann
dort auch wieder vermehrt getestet wird
auch mit steigenden insolvenzen zu
rechnen ist die menge der testungen hat
einen ganz wesentlichen einfluss darauf
wie die inzidenz gerade ist aber
bräuchte es nicht deswegen einen neuen
umgang mit dem incidents wert mit all
den begleitfaktoren die das ferienende
mit sich bringt mehr tests steigende
impfquote bislang wenig schwere verläufe
wir werden uns das anschauen und wir
werden gucken wir hatten ja immer so ein
bisschen die vorstellung auch schon
länger markenwert zu entwickeln deren
direktem zusammenhang auch mit unter
auslassung ins gesundheitssystem steht
bleiben wir jetzt auf so einer hohen ich
sag mal bugwelle von neuinfektionen
dann werden wir den sehr viel schneller
als bisher gedacht haben was genau in
einen solchen wert einfließt hat hamburg
bislang nicht festgelegt auf grundlage
der aktuellen inzidenz hat die stadt
aber konsequenzen gezogen auf dem
größten volksfest im norden dem dom sind
seit dieser woche nur noch siebeneinhalb
stadt 900.000 besucher erlaubt kein
riesenproblem so viel ist klar aber
möglicherweise ein fingerzeig was das
ferienende in deutschland noch alles mit
sich bringen wird
ganz am anfang der pandemie im januar
letzten jahres als die meisten noch nie
etwas von einer sieben tage incidents
gehört hatten und ein impfstoff noch
eine ganz ganz ferne hoffnung war für
irgendwann einmal da behandelte
professor clemens wendt nach chefarzt an
der münchen klinik die ersten deutschen
cobit patienten inzwischen ist er einer
der führenden experten berät die
bayerische und die bundesregierung guten
abend nach münchen gesamte kleber
professor rentner was kann man erreichen
wenn man die lage in zukunft nicht nur
an der inzidenz sondern auch nach
anderen daten misst
entscheidend ist für uns gerade auch im
gesundheitssystem dass wir gewisse
frühindikatoren sehen ob das system
überlastet wird belastet wird und hier
sind in ihrem filmbeitrag ja schon
entsprechende dinge genannt worden die
impfquote ist wichtig aber auch die test
quote und es gibt eben auch neue
vorschläge sehr konkrete vorschläge das
auch eine sogenannte hospitalisierung
since it ends wichtig ist also wie hoch
ist der anteil der neu infizierten
personen die wirklich ins krankenhaus
kommen müssen und dann natürlich auch
die rate der personen in prozent
gemessen die von einer normalstation auf
die intensivstation geführt werden
müssen aber sie sagen den sie ja gerade
dass man unbedingt früh erkennen muss
aber wenn jemand jetzt diese anderen
faktoren damit wie die einweisung ins
krankenhaus die ist ja später oder dann
die verlegung auf der intensivstation
und ist nach später dann wird ja die
erkenntnisse eigentlich nach hinten
verschoben statt nach vorne es ist so
die klassische 7 tages incidents ist
quasi der seismograph das sollte auch
bestehen bleiben das ist unser
frühwarnsystem
und wichtig ist dass wir doch die
vermutung haben dass eine 200 der
inzidenz bei einer sehr hohen
durchimpfungsquote immerhin haben wir
auch über 60 prozent in deutschland
geschafft nicht dasselbe bedeutet wie
eine 200er inzidenz wie im letzten jahr
also hier ist ein unterschied und das
würde ausreichen um auch im
gesundheitssystem vorkehrungen zu
treffen nun hat ja der
gesundheitsminister irgendwann mal
gesagt also wenn man diese geimpften mit
einrechnet dann wird die 50 von früher
die jetzt wird sozusagen 200 die neue 50
ich glaube das war seine formulierung
das heißt man könnte einfach großzügiger
sein ohne zu mit mit der bemessung der
inzidenz wäre das nicht besser als zu
warten bis die leute beatmet auf der
intensivstation liegen und der zug schon
wieder drei wochen weiter gefahren ist
das ist korrekt die intensiv quote ist
auch für mich ein sehr latenter faktor
die eigentlich nur zum schluss angibt
dass man hier eine reißleine ziehen muss
ist es viel besser quasi höhere
instanzen zuzulassen
eine hunderte eine 200er incident und
hier natürlich auch schon regieren zu
können die intensiv quote ist dann das
stoppschild und hier müssen dann
sozusagen auch schwere maßnahmen
einschränkung wieder eingezogen werden
nun können wir ja hoffnung haben bei die
menschen die jetzt erkranken sind der
die die noch nicht so durchgekämpft und
sind das sind die die mobilen jungen
leute die in aller regel auch nicht
schwer erkranken das heißt man kann sich
einfach sehr viel mehr infektionen
leisten wenn es um 19 50 jährige geht
als wenn es um die alten geht könnten
wir nicht alle insgesamt ein bisschen
entspannter sein und mehr freiheiten
erlauben
es ist es wichtig dass auch die
altersverteilung
bedeutsam ist für die einordnung des
pandemie geschehens
ich glaube auch dass wir
zurzeit ja auch ein entspannter sind als
wir es vielleicht vor einigen monaten
noch waren dennoch möchte ich einen
punkt ergänzen die akute belastung des
gesundheitssystems ist eine sache wir
müssen aber auch auf die spätfolgen long
beach als stichwort achten ein kind
welches nicht akut ins krankenhaus muss
kann trotzdem longo symptome entwickeln
und zum beispiel schul unfähig werden dh
das sind auch weiterhin wichtige
indikatoren die sieben tages incidents
plus die altersverteilung nun gibt es ja
auch gespräche darüber dass man auf der
anderen seite strenger wird dass man
nämlich mit einem bloßen test nirgendwo
mehr reinkommt dass also die wirklich
attraktiven dinge wie zum beispiel
kinobesuch partybesuch theater und so
weiter nur noch möglich ist wenn man
entweder gelesen oder geimpft ist aus
medizinischer sicht sie sind kein
politiker aus medizinischer sicht würde
das sinn machen und was bringen
ich denke schon dass wir diese berühmte
formel von 3g auf zweig umschalten
sozusagen auch die getesteten nichts
akzeptieren gewissen bereichen dass das
sinn macht weil wir wissen zum teil dass
diese schnelltests je nachdem wie sie
durchgeführt werden auch nicht unbedingt
valide sind
wir wissen auch dass sie falsch negativ
sein können es wäre ideal pcr test hier
einzufordern und das ist zwar schon auch
ein konzept was in diesem neuen
vorschlag integriert ist das eben bei
erreichen der höchsten warnstufe auch
getestete dann in gewissen bereichen
nicht hinein dürfen die erkenntnisse
eines mediziners dankeschön nach münchen
sehr gerne herr kleber und im
heute-journal update gegen viertel vor
eins spricht nah sein möchte mir dann zu
dem thema mit karl lauterbach und nur
nachrichten von gundula gause der streik
bei der bahn soll um zwei uhr in der
nacht beendet werden mit zusätzlichen
zügen will die bahn morgen das reisen
wieder problemlos ermöglichen die
lokführergewerkschaft gdl hat mit ihrem
streik auch heute wieder große teile des
schienenverkehrs lahmgelegt nur etwa ein
viertel aller fernzüge fuhr die gdl
fordert 3,2 prozent mehr lohn sowie eine
corona prämie von 600 euro damit will
sie sich auch im machtkampf mit der
größeren eisenbahngewerkschaft evg
positionieren kommende woche wird die
gdl über weitere streiks entscheiden
bei der flutkatastrophe sind im
rheinland-pfälzischen aartal nach
neuesten erkenntnissen der polizei 133
menschen ums leben gekommen von den 141
geborgenen toten dort seien acht keine
flut opfer gewesen sondern vor der
hochwasserkatastrophe bereits verstorben
heute vor vier wochen hatte extremer
starkregen an der aare eine flutwelle
ausgelöst und weite teile des tals
zerstört auch die winzer branche dort
ist schwer getroffen allein ihre schäden
werden auf 160 millionen euro geschätzt
bei schweren überschwemmungen und
erdrutschen in der türkischen
schwarzmeer region sind mindestens neun
menschen ums leben gekommen
die wassermassen zerstörten häuser und
brücken und rissen autos mit sich nach
behördenangaben waren mehr als 1000
rettungskräfte in den nördlichen
provinzen im einsatz auch mit
hubschraubern
um menschen zu retten die sich auf ihren
hausdächern in schuss gebracht
zugleich leidet südeuropa weiter unter
extremer hitze und immer neuen
waldbränden leichte entspannung brachte
regen für teile griechenlands
zwar seien aktuell alle feuer unter
kontrolle
die gefahr aber noch nicht vorbei sagte
der griechische ministerpräsident
mitsotakis in italien ist die lage
weiter angespannt mit
48,8 grad hat die messstation a syrakus
in sizilien einen neuen temperaturrekord
gemessen auch algerien kämpft weiter mit
den flammen für die mindestens 69
todesopfer der waldbrände dort hat die
regierung in algier eine dreitägige
staatstrauer angeordnet die geplante
änderung am polnischen medien gesetz
stößt international auf kritik
us-außenminister blinken nannte das
vorhaben
beunruhigend die eu kommission verwies
darauf dass starke demokratie nicht
gegen medien pluralismus und
meinungsvielfalt kämpfen wird die
gestern im parlament beschlossene
änderung gesetz erhalten nicht europäer
keine rundfunk lizenz mehr betroffen
davon wäre zb die tvn gruppe mit ihrem
in polen populären regierungskritischen
programm der sender gehört einem
us-konzern
im osten afrikas im t3 im norden
äthiopiens eines der ältesten
christlichen länder der erde liegt der
tatort von verbrechen die kaum zu
beschreiben sind dabei war äthiopien ein
leuchtturm der hoffnung als abu ahmed
den diktatorischen vorgänger ablöste und
den krieg mit dem erzfeind eritrea
beendete er bekam dafür den
friedensnobelpreis
das war sicher zu früh und fast sicher
ein fehler
menschenrechtsorganisationen wie amnesty
international berichten aus der
abtrünnigen provinz bas truppen sexuelle
gewalt als mittel des krieges einsetzen
um den willen der feinde zu brechen da
richtet sich die brutalität gegen die
schwachen das muss die welt ist
sie ist erst 27 jahre alt doch ihr leben
so sagt sie ist schon jetzt zerstört die
junge frau aus der nord äthiopischen
provinz tigray hat schreckliches erlebt
der waren 23 soldaten in der wüste ich
war völlig überrumpelt diese 23 haben
eine frau vergewaltigt mich als sie
schrie haben sie mich fast erwürgt die
täter drohten ihr die kehle
durchzuschneiden
ihre beine waren gebrochen ohne hilfe
kommt sie nicht aus dem bett noch heute
hat sie blutungen der arzt georgia may
behandelt seit monaten frauen wie sie
frauen liebe es braucht und verstümmelt
wurden und die mit letzter kraft in
seine kimi kommen
oft müssen wir sie operieren wir müssen
nägel steine plastik gegenstände
entfernen und dabei bluten sie die ganze
zeit
sexualisierte gewalt als kriegswaffe
überlebende berichten von monatelange
gefangenschaft
vergewaltigungen auch von mädchen die
brutalität sei extrem klagt die
menschenrechtsorganisation amnesty
international in ihrem neuesten bericht
an
wir sehen dass sexuelle gewalt gegen
frauen und mädchen integra weit
verbreitet ist da niemand dafür zur
rechenschaft gezogen wird muss die
internationale gemeinschaft eingreifen
insbesondere die afrikanische union und
die vereinten nationen
die täter sind soldaten sowohl der
eritreischen wie der äthiopischen armee
seit ende letzten jahres kämpfen sie
gemeinsam gegen die volksbefreiungsfront
tplf die in der provinz tigray herrscht
erbittert verteidigt die tplf 1 in der
regierung diese letzte verbliebene
region äthiopien kontakt mit dem
zeitweisen abschneiden t kreis von jeder
versorgung weil hilfskonvois nur noch
schwer bis t3 kommen auch helfer bereits
getötet wurden werden nahrungsmittel und
medikamente knapp die logistischen
hindernissen nicht nur für das
un-welternährungsprogramm
sind enorm
vor allem versuchen wir lebensmittel von
einem teil äthiopiens natürlichkeit zu
bringen es gibt viele hindernisse 3 es
gibt nur einen weg nach tigra der ist
450 kilometer lang und führt durch
unwirtliches gelände mit mindestens acht
oder zehn check points an der straße
den äthiopischen premierminister ficht
das nicht an im gegenteil der kürzlich
wiedergewählte abu ahmed rief gerade
erst die tube ja zu den waffen sie
sollen sich für die armee melden und den
feind in die tiefe lf zu bekämpfen es
ist ein blutiger konflikt mit tausenden
von opfern und 170 tausend menschen die
auf der flucht sind
von da muss es weitergehen mit
nachrichten
der wirtschaft der energiekonzern rwe
hat für das erste halbjahr gute zahlen
vorgelegt belastet aber ist die bilanz
durch auswirkungen der wetter extreme so
hat die flutkatastrophe im westen
deutschlands auch bei rwe einen
millionenschaden verursacht sina mainitz
zugleich muss der energiekonzern
versorgungssicherheit gewähren wie geht
rwe diese herausforderungen an das ist
tatsächlich schon ein spagat der da
geleistet werden muss rwe verbindet man
nicht mehr nur mit atomstrom und
kohlekraft sondern inzwischen auch mit
einem grünen energie mix aber dieser
ökostrom kurs macht eben auch anfällig
für wetter- extreme sei es die
kältewelle in texas im februar die
windräder stoppte oder die
flutkatastrophe hierzulande aktuell
allein sie kostete den konzern 35
millionen euro
künftig will rwe seine anlagen besser
schützen und sich gegen strom
lieferverpflichtungen absichern außerdem
fordert der konzern zusätzliche flächen
für wind- und solarparks das senkt
transportkosten ebenso sollen
wasserstoffwirtschaft und gaskraftwerke
aufgebaut werden die energiewende ist
bei rwe längst angekommen klimaneutral
produzierter strom wird als erstes
verkauft mit energie zertifikaten viel
geld verdient ideen sind da und
investoren stehen bereit wenn ein
unternehmen grün und nachhaltig
wirtschaftet an der börse überraschte
rwe heute wenig der dax dafür umso mehr
ein neues allzeithoch mit einem plus von
0,7 prozent und am ende 15
1938 punkten einen unternehmens wandel
gepaart mit dem klimawandel stemmen das
wird der kraftakt für die deutschen
wirtschaft in den kommenden jahren so
ist es vielen langen finger nach
frankfurt gerne die deutsche handball
nationalmannschaft muss sich nach dem
enttäuschenden olympia turnier neu
aufstellen kapitän uwe gensheimer
erklärte seinen rücktritt aus der dhb
auswahl außerdem muss bundestrainer
gislason auf weitere routiniers
verzichten auch linkshänder steffen
weinhold zieht sich zurück abwehrchef
hendrik pekeler will eine längere pause
einlegen und
torhüter johannes bitter will nur noch
für notfälle zur verfügung stehen
in lübeck ist nach sechsjähriger
sanierung die historische carlebach
synagoge wieder eröffnet worden jüdisch
zu leben sagte schleswig holsteins
ministerpräsident günther durfte nie
wieder etwas sein das man verstecken
müsse
1878 war das jüdische gotteshaus nach
dem vorbild der berliner neuen synagoge
erbaut worden in der ns zeit wurde sie
bei den novemberpogrome 1938
zwar verwüstet aber nicht wie so viele
synagogen ganz zerstört heute hat die
jüdische gemeinde in lübeck etwa 600
mitglieder
am 13 august
1961 morgen vor 60 jahren begann in
berlin der bau einer mauer die
deutschland teilte und aus west berlin
eine isolierte insel machte es war ein
dramatischer schachzug er riskierte den
kalten krieg zu einem neuen wahren krieg
zu machen aber walter ulbricht in
ostberlin und nikita chruschtschow in
moskau seien keine alternative das volk
der ddr vor allem junge dynamische
menschen setzen sich in massen nach
westen ab angelockt von freiheit und dem
kapitalistischen versprechen das konnte
die ddr auf dauer nicht aushalten so
gesehen war das tatsächlich ein
schutzwall für den arbeiter und
bauernstaat und das sozialistische
modell
nüchtern betrachtet wuchs er zu einer
monströsen
menschenverachtenden maschine
ausgeklügelt um jede flucht
abzuschrecken und trotzdem gab es
menschen die der partei glaubten dass
das notwendig und gerechtfertigt sei
christhard läpple spiegelt diese
geschichte an einem mann der damals
glaubte das richtige zu tun und einer
der prominentesten dissidenten der ddr
wurde
ostberlin freitag elfter august 61
ein unscheinbarer aushang an der
humboldt universität
dort steht sondern früh 6 uhr appell im
hauptgebäude in aller herrgottsfrühe ist
der 24 jährige wolf biermann am 13
august dabei die studenten sollen die
neue mauer erklären wie man alt mit
flugblättern bewaffnet los
wir sollten alle im wohnhäuser gehen die
unmittelbar an dieser grenze liegen
damit wir den bewohnern dort
erklären dass die maßnahme unserer
regierung nämlich die schließung der
grenze nur eine vorübergehende maßnahme
ist
biermann klingelt die bürger aus dem
schlaf er soll sie überzeugen die neue
grenze sichere den frieden sie werde den
westen hindern im osten geschäfte leer
zu kaufen und menschen abzufahren die
hamburger biermann war mit 17 in die ddr
gezogen der junge aus einer kommunisten
familie wollte das bessere deutschland
aufbauen
wir wollten nicht dass die ddr
zusammenbricht und hofften dass wir im
schutze dieser mauer jetzt endlich offen
reden können und das erwies sich als
eine illusion
je länger sich die ddr ein mord desto
mehr empfindet er das land als großes
gefängnis die grenze ist für ihn kein
akt der stärke sondern eine
bankrotterklärung
aus dem labor machte er ein drama das in
seinem neuen theater aufgeführt werden
soll eine liebesgeschichte in berliner
braut gang verliebt sich ein arbeiter
aus dem vw bremsen werk in die tochter
des chefarztes als diese flüchtet
versucht er sie zurückzuholen vergeblich
er scheitert genau wie das stück das
trotz sechsfacher änderungen der zensur
zum opfer fällt
trotzdem verboten weil es nicht verlogen
genug war die bomben waren nicht so dumm
wie ich schlau sein wollte und
haben natürlich kapiert der tut so als
aber für die mauer ist und in
wirklichkeit ist das schlimmer als wenn
er gegen die mauer wäre denn der sagt
die gründe warum wir die mauer gebaut
haben dass es eben kein
antifaschistischer schutzwall
sein mauer drama wird 1963 verboten das
theater geschlossen das sed parteibuch
verweigert ein faustschlag fürs leben so
biermann
976 wird der liedermacher aus der ddr
ausgebürgert
dauerte freilich wie wenige dauern leben
so habe ich dann gesungen verstehen sie
die ganze wut darüber dass
bei einer episode
das ganze leben von generationen kaputt
geht und
das ist mein gefühl einer mauer bis
heute ist biermann in der deutschen
frage zerrissen aber die mauer bleibt
für ihn der größte irrtum der ddr
es gibt von christhard läpple eine
faszinierende dokumentation drei junge
männer in uniform die damals für den
osten im osten an der grenze standen
ihre ddr zu schützen und ihre haltung
damals und ihre leben danach zeigen die
ganze bandbreite deutscher
nachkriegsgeschichte am todesstreifen
sie finden das in der mediathek morgen
übertragen wir ab 59 die
gedenkveranstaltung an den mauerbau aus
berlin und berichten dann am abend
wieder hier im heute journal
[Musik]
guten abend die hitzewelle hat jetzt das
westliche mittelmeer erreicht dort lagen
die temperaturen heute bei 40 bis 50
grad da war es doch bei uns deutlich
angenehmer und jetzt in der nacht sinken
die temperaturen am oberrhein auf 20
grad sonst wird es meist etwas kühler
und auch heute nacht haben sie häufig
nur einen klaren sternenhimmel sieht
allerdings anders aus hier aus der
schweiz und aus den alpen heraus da kann
es in der zweiten nachthälfte schauer
und gewitter geben wie dann aber wohl
recht rasch wieder in sich
zusammenfallen so erwartet uns ein sehr
freundlicher vormittag mit sonnenschein
und wolken nachmittags entwickeln sich
in dieser kühlen luft aber neue schauer
und gewitter vom schwarzwald bis etwa
zum thüringer wald und auch in bayern
sind einige kräftige gewitter nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen auch im nordwesten ändert
sich was da ziehen von der nordsee
dichtere wolken heran wie bringen noch
etwas regen mit und deswegen steigen
morgen die temperaturen an der
nordseeküste nur auf 22 23 grad sonst
werden 26 bis 31 grad erreicht und diese
dichteren wolken an der nordsee die
machen sich auch beim uv index bemerkbar
dort bekommen sie nicht so schnell einen
sonnenbrand wie im süden deutschlands
und mit diesem sommerwetter geht es auch
in den nächsten tagen weiter von
nordwesten wird allerdings wechselhafter
da kommt dann immer mehr regen dazu und
deswegen wäre mein tipp vielleicht
nutzen sie die nächsten tage mal für
einen abendspaziergang der nächste woche
stehen die zeichen eindeutig auf herbst
guten abend